you
all right we are almost underway there's
a pretty big turnout already 77 players
at the very start of this one all right
no yes let's go at this let's see what
you throw at me take okay counsel when I
get in c4 let me ask this bishop a
question first
maybe even the queen who okay that's a
pretty interesting move I'm gonna put
that night in a pin if he's not careful
get out of there
let's try and break down their Kings
side a little bit all right
Oh King G 2 minutes exchanges I guess I
still have the bishop pair Oh watch out
for this pawn here take him I should be
able to convert this without an issue
start with this guy in a lie square
offer a trade get him on a light square
let's take get this guy going good king
position you're ready to expand stopping
that
progress
making progress know at this sequence
okay now they have to be careful because
these guys continue to march just keep
my king position continue with the king
position keep on pushing my bishops
there to defend hunt this guy down for
seconds now you goof almost there
get that clean
downtime I'll take it oh it's our rat
race I got to all right Sicilian land
stop Bishop takes f7 I like being able
to expand with tempo there
let's stop d4
prevent potential pins against my night
this is a good square for a night or
Bishop now we have a four versus three
on the Queen side
yeah let's trade my queen will be well
placed here in an exchange get out of
there
Wow
what's that queen up to okay going all
the greedy after that guy really dare
you do that I'm on the Queen Queen here
I was gonna do that I'm up a queen mean
up on what's this rook up to he's gone
mad he'll look up and over smashing
through an f2 Queen takes Bishop Queen
takes rook take that one and we got me
in a couple Rafi one is an only move
they resigned back to tournament for
still on page two 142 players are in
this one all right
I saw Nona Fry's revenge in there who's
in top I didn't get to it soon enough
top is at 8 points I'm in 19th all right
this guy haven't played before let's
secure Queen on c7 fianchetto huh
I don't know how nice that my bishops I
don't think he stands well and b4 okay
I'll take him out
I guess they could take twice here huh
let's do that and then offset their
Bishop get out of this pin Queen trade
don't here and go after these pawns are
you a knight
or do you want to be let's go here first
then here let's grab that pawn I get
this one I wasn't good kind of going
astray here hmm all right when I offset
this rook prove my king position rook
here
pinpoint that secure my king I want him
to be able to go to g6 fine with this
ending now I could get this pawn king
he'll be flush to h7 maybe it's a
nail-biter on the clock let's come over
here all right keep pushing do no right
on the clock back to tournament oof
sixteen twelve nine eight
I'm at eight okay Oh second time we've
played second time we're playing go with
the pawn trio
okay let's defend my night out of the
way I'm targeting d3 right now I mean
here Bishop d7 I'm stopping Queen beats
free I guess I have to do this now yeah
is this working out I guess it is mmm
spending too much time clean trade
happening soon let's make sure I could
offset that night defend I feel like I'm
tactically vulnerable here really really
tactically vulnerable Queen a5 ah let's
try this when I get out of harm's way
Bishop h6 yeah mm-hmm get the bishop at
least move my bishop there rook I didn't
see that I think we had Queen there
maybe
how I got out of that somehow eight
seconds why was I just not moving there
I don't have any time
oh they're down on time
thank goodness oh man this is too
intense man
too many intense games 21 ah you know
what it is at this thing I'm just still
so distracted my mind is on the previous
game when I started a next game whoo
okay avoid that night exchange there you
go
be a pest no soup for you type moves I
could have gone with Bishop f4 right
away what's the matter with you there is
a think tank I love it yes right there
huh kick him around get my rook on the
e-file soon the knight moves I get d6
their queen is opposite my bishop I
don't know let's try for this
maybe b4
don't know what that move is okay oh my
goodness is that really what I wanted to
do give up my queen
ah awful man awful not cool no chance no
chance in-betweener no 15 seconds could
always take my rook now they're going to
do it
Oh
last part favorite clothes to lose they
got time oh I'll take the draw and
undeserved result clearly clearly Bishop
d1 you don't want to disconnect your
looks like that ever again okay let's go
with a king side for yet oh that's an
early capture on d5 all right they're
gonna shoot for some control over c5 and
they have just that I should be looking
for this stuff though let's poke around
a little bit that rook play a four I
have c5 but my bishop is actually pretty
good so I could pinpoint their beep on
actually it's very simplified okay
playing playing on in this one slight
space advantage on the Kings side it's
going to be very telling watch out for
that Jeep body's dangerous he's a
dangerous dangerous pawn should I just
offer a trial hall for a trial are we
planning on in this is that what we're
doing you might be playing on here oh my
goodness okay we're playing on
okay opposition time where you at a
position a position opposition
opposition crowd and all over it
actually I think if they played a four
before I played a four I was going to be
in a difficult spot 16 15 15 15 I'm in
14th who's in first okay
somebody has 34 somebody who came up
with the creative name this is only a
test ready all right
there you go and that's a queen whoa
really now let's do that first and make
sure we get rid of this pesky night huh
you're no good buddy you're no good IRA
pesky Bishop I meant 39 seconds let's
grab a pawn and centralize I guess I'm
down that light square bishop they only
have 10 seconds play year next focus on
g6 I don't know trade their Bishop isn't
playing well let's take the rook first
and then here no back rancors do that
they're down on time
okay 34 22 22 21 17 I'm at 17 10 minutes
left and I'm in 10th can he come back
somehow
not too far off last three games didn't
net me four points efore
all right applying the doctor let's try
for a quick f4 Knight f3
in that order all right give me the a
file development in one shot keep this
file open Knight h5 I'm gonna see my
Knights gonna go to f5 super Knight
threatening mate waiting it's some
material next I want to get rid of their
Bishop Bishop takes pawn I have c3
threatening mate in two actually
no Queen trade rook g3 serious pressure
g2 is collapsing
no Queen trade takes and they have a
fork don't they yes they do
all right so much for that I should
still have some pressure against their
king Wow to defend my back rank a little
bit Queen take c2 would have been fine
and they missed that lateral defense of
III they resigned and I ran right into a
fork didn't really convert that well
clearly 190 of you are in this one stay
away from Knight f3
okay let's try this again f4 Knight f3 I
don't have to worry about my bishop
getting hunted down with the night going
to d7 let's move forward punch up the
Queen Knight d5 could be a pretty good
move
yeah especially now strikes at c7
controls f6 there f7 pawn is pinned
let's jump right in
f6 c 7g 4 where's the knight go after g4
mm-hmm preparing g4 I don't want to jump
right in there
how about Knight g4 might have to
preserve my bishop I didn't see that
they moved their stubble up oh they're
Knight is a bit of a bother let's go
here I want to keep a minor piece on
board now let's do this let's that move
about
I'll take him I guess he was sort of
scaring me maybe one threat all right
take care and now I'm gonna show that
that a pawn was significant because
we're gonna trade a bunch and can you
catch my pawn
you could my king will make progress
somehow there you go King vacuum up
these pawns and they're down at I'm 42
27 26 I'm at 23 big battle for second 6
minutes left I have fire a few others
have fire here in this close group might
have 6 maybe I should go
for e5 and Knight f6 stuff all right
let's get this e5 move in okay we're
gonna take and develop my queen here is
pretty aggressive
let's get that night out of there on c4
I have e6 under control my bishop let's
open up this side of the board where
their king is maybe drop this pawn in
the process 85 I don't know here they're
gonna give up their strong Knight they
are hmm what am i doing with my knight
okay
yeah this is trouble for me preparing to
display this move kind of keep it closed
relying heavily on my knight it seems to
be working out it's I think they're
having some difficulty adjusting to the
structural change let's approach with my
King just defend these points and you
want to keep that around actually my
King defends the knight let's get this
pawn going a little bit dislodge this
Bishop and they dislodge my knight oh no
they missed that that Bishop out of
there mmm it's gonna hunt down that
bishop
let's cut him off still cut off okay we
got it on the clock at least okay
they're down at time and position was
good okay 3427 50:34 27 29 okay just out
of podium territory this guy's going so
fast I didn't even realize already a
couple of his moves were played okay
it's Queen c2 huh that's not really
doing anything but dropping upon okay I
have to play this one down upon may be
down another if I'm not careful clean
trade I guess uh-huh another offer of a
queen exchange being down two pawns now
all I have is the file now I don't have
the file now all I have is a rook just a
silly little rook and they have a lot
more time rook exchange would have been
fine rook a for probably would have
resigned no my kiddin you don't resign
it's not in here it's not in your blood
I'll just drop another pawn though I
always consider that get active with
your rep it's the only thing you have
it's the only thing you have give checks
dislodge the King position be a pest
with your rook another check get behind
cut the King off no grab a pawn got this
guy I'm on the rook convenience there
King
what's the delay man what is the delay
um Wow surprisingly I couldn't now I
could do this two seconds I could have
burned I'm down on time oh okay got
another game I wouldn't have even been
in podium land there I go again
see I forget I forget stay away from
Knight f3 break a pin there Knight c4
Knight c3 ah that's too bad
silly silly silly okay let's back up
focus on c5 I still need a flight square
third rook can't go too far now that
their king is in the corner where is he
going
what's the scoop with this guy all right
I'm gonna take there and look at some
pin stuff Oh oh no I gotta go here
their queen is restricted they're not
moving come on f7 and the bishop okay
now we're crashing through broke up and
over they resigned Charma was over
though roof closed for maybe third but
that's about it
56:36 33 were top three I had 27 but
these games here the
here there was a sequence of
back-to-back draws that really played a
role yeah
and then that loss at the end of course
all right 199 of you were in that one
all right
good games all
you